we have breaking news this morning from
france where an investigation has found
a horrifying number of abuse cases
linked to the roman catholic church
chris libsay is in rome with a report
that was just released a short time ago
chris good morning what can you tell us
good morning gail the shocking inquiry
found an estimated 216
000 child sex abuse victims at the hands
of french clergy between 1950 and 2020.
now the report says an estimated 3 000
abusers two-thirds of them priests
worked in the church during that period
one vatican insider told cbs news that
the staggering number of priests means
there is likely irrefutable evidence of
a cover-up the figures are based on
research after the commission spent two
and a half years listening to victims
through an open hotline and studying
church court and police archives it's
the latest and possibly highest number
of victims revealed in reports and
investigations worldwide that have
helped lift the veil of silence around
church sex abuse
francis catholic bishops have asked
victims for forgiveness the vatican has
yet to comment gail
thank you very much chris let's say
reporting from rome